hello and welcome to math simplified i
am dr umar malik and in this video we
will discuss about the 5 best and 5
worst foods for people with acid reflux
disease and the logic behind it
acid reflux disease is also known as
gastroesophageal reflux disease which is
one of the most common diseases around
the world and is known to significantly
impair your lifestyle and lead to
serious complications in long term if
not managed properly if you want to know
more about the acid reflux disease click
the link in the i button above to watch
our previous video in which we have
discussed in detail about acid reflux
disease and its treatment
heartburn is a common symptom of acid
reflux you can also experience a burning
sensation in your stomach or chest after
eating a full meal or certain foods
gastroesophageal reflux disease can also
cause vomiting or regurgitation as acid
moves into your esophagus
other symptoms of acid reflux disease
include dry cough
sore throat
bloating
burping or hiccups difficulty swallowing
and a feeling of lump in the throat
to give you an idea of how widespread
this problem has become a 2014
systematic review estimated that about
15 to 25 percent of u.s population has
acid reflux disease according to the
health care cost and utilization project
there were about 3.14 million
hospitalizations for acid reflux disease
in 2005 and in 2010 this number has
increased to 4.7 million
hospitalizations and has led to 1653
deaths
acid reflux disease is also a lifestyle
disease like diabetes obesity and
hypertension
lifestyle habits like taking too much
stress smoking and eating the wrong type
of diet are one of the key factors that
lead to acid reflux disease
in this video we will focus on the diet
related to acid reflux disease 5 foods
that you should definitely avoid and
five foods that you should include in
your diet that will help you to relieve
and manage acid reflux disease so let's
first start with the five worst foods
for people with acid reflux disorder
number one high fat foods the following
foods have a very high fat content avoid
these completely or limit them from your
diet
fast food like french fries burgers
onion drinks full fat dairy products
such as whole milk butter and cheese
fatty or fried beef
pork or lamb
desserts or snacks such as ice cream and
potato chips creamy sauces and gravies
oily and greasy foods fried and fatty
foods can cause the lower esophageal
sphincter to relax when it shouldn't be
lower esophageal sphincter is a ring of
smooth muscles at the junction of your
esophagus and the stomach that allows
only unidirectional movement of foods
and liquids
this muscle only relaxes when you
swallow food
fried in fatty foods can cause the lower
esophageal sphincter to relax when it
shouldn't be allowing the stomach acid
to back up into the esophagus
these foods also delay stomach emptying
eating high fat foods puts you at a
greater risk for reflux symptoms so
reducing your total daily intake of fat
can definitely help
number two is caffeine caffeine is a
known trigger of acid reflux it
stimulates your stomach to secrete more
acid which can regurgitate into your
esophagus and lead to heartburn
a study was done on 16 patients to note
the effects of removing caffeine from
their coffee known as decaffeination and
its effects on the symptoms of acid
reflux disease
the study concluded that regular coffee
led to a significant acid reflux and
decaffeination of coffee significantly
decreased the acid reflux so it's best
to avoid your morning cup of coffee and
find other alternatives like tea or
decaffeinated coffee if you are
constantly suffering from acid reflux
symptoms
number three are chocolates chocolates
contain chemicals like methylxanthines
caffeine and theobromine which relax
your smooth muscles including the one
that is present in your lower esophageal
sphincter
this causes the acid in your stomach to
move up in your esophagus more easily
and leads to symptoms of acid reflux so
avoid chocolates
number four is alcohol alcohol has two
negative effects for people suffering
with acid reflux
first alcohol is known stimulant for the
production of acid in your stomach so it
increases the quantity of acid that is
produced by your stomach and second it
also causes the lower esophageal
sphincter to relax
this leads to more reflux so avoid
alcohol at all costs as it is one of the
worst food for people with acid reflux
number five are citrus fruits now fruits
and vegetables are very important in a
healthy diet but certain fruits can
cause or worsen gastroesophageal reflux
disease symptoms especially highly
acidic fruits if you are having frequent
acid reflux you should reduce or
eliminate your intake of the following
fruits
oranges
grapefruits lemons
limes
pineapples
tomatoes and tomato sauces
so it's best to avoid these types of
foods
later in this video we will discuss some
fruits and vegetables that are very good
for people with acid reflux
so these were five types of foods that
you should avoid if you have acid reflux
disease now let's talk about the five
types of foods that are very beneficial
for people with acid reflux disease
number one is ginger
ginger is one of the best digestive aids
because of its medicinal properties it
is alkaline in nature and
anti-inflammatory which eases irritation
in the digestive tract the best way to
consume ginger for people with acid
reflux is to make ginger tea or you can
also chew on some dried ginger that will
also help you to relieve the symptoms of
acid reflux
number two is oatmeal
many people with acid reflux disease
note that their symptoms of acidity
begin soon after breakfast this is
usually because we take the wrong type
of food in our breakfast first thing in
the morning like bacon sausages donuts
which are fatty and sugary foods that
increase the acid reflux
oatmeal is a better choice many patients
report an improvement in the symptoms of
acid reflux when they switch their
breakfast to oatmeal also it's got
plenty of fiber which is good for your
gut
number three is yogurt
not only is yogurt soothing to an
irritated esophagus but it also provides
probiotics that supports your digestive
tract it is also a good source of
protein yogurt that is not too sore is
also excellent for acid reflux because
of the probiotics that can help you to
normalize the bowel function
yogurt also provides protein and soothes
stomach discomfort often providing a
cooling sensation
number four are lean proteins
low fat lean sources of proteins also
reduce acid reflux symptoms
good choices are eggs these are high in
protein however if eggs are a problem to
you stick to the whites only and stay
clear of the higher fat yolks which are
more likely to cause symptoms
and second good source of lean proteins
is lean meat
high fat meals and fried foods tend to
decrease lower esophageal sphincter
pressure and delay stomach emptying
increasing the reflux choosing lean meat
that is grilled broiled or baked is good
for people with acid reflux
now let's talk about the fruits and
vegetables that are very beneficial for
patients with acid reflux symptoms
fruits like watermelon which is a very
good option as it is a low acid fruit
which won't trigger your symptoms other
fruits like bananas melons
apples and pears among others are
non-citrus fruits which are very good
for people with acid reflux
talking about the vegetables raw or
cooked vegetables are generally good for
acid reflux diet be sure to avoid onions
tomatoes or peppers recommended
vegetables include all root vegetables
like potatoes sweet potatoes turnips and
carrots other great vegetables include
mushrooms fennel and celery
so these were the five best and five
worst foods for people with acid reflux
disease
make sure to watch our video explaining
the details of acid reflux disease and
its treatment
hope you like the video you can support
med simplified by joining our channel
here on youtube or patreon.com links are
in the description below thank you so
much for watching see you in the next
video